this show is brought to you by Dr Sarah
go to DS gear and check out their
extremely high quality functional gear
that's made with hemp textiles they have
bags Keys rash guards and more they have
T-shirts they have fanny packs go to
dsgear.com and use Cobra Joey to save
five percent the show is also brought to
you by anna.com go to anna.com and use
code word church to save 10 on all of
their optimization products like strong
bone Alpha Brain new mood stream tech
immune and shroom Tech sport it's Cobra
church at onit.com to save 10 percent
oh [__] drop it Lee kick that [__]
meal leak oh
Wednesday
August 10th [__] what
oh [__] Lee Syed
Susanna Lee
she'll be coming in a little later
and your uncle [__] Joey on a
Wednesday night what else are you gonna
be doing what what kick it Lee
oh [__] out of that nut sack
it's your [__] lucky night right here
popsuckers what
oh [__] do I think you're a nasty girl I
love it you filthy animal you give me
those dirty feet and those stinky ankles
oh yeah
what up you bad [__] Wednesday
nights
DJ Lee cut the [__] music you're over
there like turning it off like
somebody's gonna jump off a cliff you
know ain't nobody jumping off a [__]
clip here
what's going on my little brother
I'm having a good day man [__] that weed
is good it's a good night [__] yeah it's
Wednesday night everything's
crack-a-lackin we're back on you know I
feel a lot better I was a little under
the weather there I I can't smoke pot
with a lot of people
I get sick
and right away like that night when I
left here just hitting that vapor pen
with the kid from Eureka yeah you just
knew I just knew when I went home that
night I got up at four in the morning my
throat was already scratchy
by the time I got up at [__] uh seven
I was spitting colors and [__] you know
three days I didn't know you're gonna be
sick yeah you know and here's the
problem when you're sick that you go you
know what I got this and you go do
something stupid and you break the sweat
and you leave the t-shirt on and here
you are for six weeks coughing
you know those two week calls and you
finally go to the doctor to give you a
description
this is why you have to really watch
especially my age especially you know
I'm thinking about how I got sick two
weeks after the surgery because those
antibiotics clean out your [__]
system so your immune system is weak
it's building back up I got back on a
plane I got second on a plane you know
this is the [__] that happened it's just
getting some this is just a simple cold
but you can't do much with it you know
for a fact that if you [__]
Juggernaut this thing it could either
get really bad or it could shake why
take the chance I gotta go to Denver
this week I gotta do five [__] shows
Thursday sold out already why do I take
a chance I just relaxed I did not go to
Jujitsu all week between the [__] arm
and the cold and the whole [__] deal
I just said you know what again just
relax why kill yourself
I don't want to turn this into an
ammonia and then I get on the [__]
plan that gets worse and I go from high
altitude and then we got a [__]
problem all weekend and not to mention
like rolling it's like the same as
smoking with someone if you roll it with
someone they get up and then they're
sneezing they have a cold I'm like what
the [__] man they're sweating on me so
what I do is just intent to myself I did
a little writing I made some notes you
know [__] like that it wasn't the
biggest week of my life I gotta move
so I really started throwing some [__]
out some T-shirts [__] I don't wear [__]
I found that even though I still had
shoes just I'm doing the first sweep the
next week I'm doing the most intense
week when I get home then I go out
Oddball and then when I come back we
make the move you got to give me the
movies numbers we get them on [__]
point oh yeah the bed's coming from
Helix sleep except it's a bed the whole
[__] deal so it's over
it's uh it can be really stressful
moving it could be if you let it be if
you put yourself in a predicament of a
two dare and then you want to cut
corners and borrow a truck from your
friend and then your other buddy's gonna
come that's a mind [__] right there
so when I've done the last two times is
I start moving boxes over on the 15th
they did the lawn today tomorrow's the
painting and I guess next week is the
carpeting and right after that I start
moving over there three boxes a night
when I leave here after the podcast
three boxes a night
I'm not doing nothing at 2 30 in the
afternoon three boxes three boxes three
boxes three boxes three boxes
I'm pretty pretty soon when the movies
come
it's a [__]
it's three hours because we're right
around the [__] Corner yeah the only
it's totally taken but donating the
couches they smell like cat piss we're
taking the TV the [__] bedroom the
kids room that's it we can't carry the
refrigerator down because it might break
the [__] stairs and we can't take the
oven so what what are we taking
the pictures
the bathroom [__] that's it the clothes
and the cabinets that's it
so I could start taking the winter
clothes over there ready suits
shirts you know and that's how you do it
the books I got in that Library stuff
going over there
let the movers move the two desks the
mattresses the bedroom the baby's
bedroom
that's it boxes we're gonna take dishes
over the dish like she's already got all
that back the [__] that's not we don't
use on The Daily get that [__] out of
here get it out so that shit's gone she
already cleaned the cabinets for
groceries like the [__] that's expired
we don't really use we travel light us
Puerto Ricans travel like [__]
dude I used I I've moved alcohol like I
pack I don't throw anything away
can't I can't throw away I I literally
have a box that I bring but I take the
stuff from my fridge I'm like all right
no I take this [__] from my fridge okay
I but this [__] that like tartar sauce
you know it's tartar sauce that's half
full and the sides are crusted what are
you gonna take that for us no uh what's
the red [__] what's ketchup no the other
[__] cocktail sauce yeah that [__] gets
all crusty thrown away it's a dollar 49
on special you can make it at your
[__] house I'm gonna carry that [__]
with me to the falls and you got it on
your fingers and you touch your sweater
now you got that red chin on your face
there's a thousand things that don't
need to really go no I don't know it's
not worth the [__] aggravation it's
it like because you're getting a house
so it's cool that you get to move in
early I've always ever since no no we're
gonna move boxes early right but we
don't move till like September 1st is
complete oh yeah no no I understand but
what I'm saying is like ever since I
moved out I've lived in apartments and
with that you only have like a day so I
never
as broke as I was I never once asked
friends to help me move I've always paid
because it just
we were talking before the podcast
started about how like you start
realizing how much stuff costs like if
you're on vacation or something I was
thinking about that the other like last
night I bought something I was like
that's like half an hour of work or
whatever when you start realizing how
much time it takes to actually buy
something that you're buying
like you'll start
you either start buying less or you'll
realize that your time is important so
rather than spending four days moving
just hire movers for 300 bucks
I feel the same way
if you think I want to go up and down
stairs in the morning with [__]
couches and [__]
I can't handle that not three days of
that no it's not worth my health it's
not nothing especially for what we're
moving like I said to you we got [__]
Salvation Army on point they're picking
up the couches the chairs we're taking
the two TVs
the babies TV [__] like that the baby's
room is the toughest believe it or not
because she's the most stuff yeah but
we're taking all her clothes over and
boxes over the moving thing is
preparation it's like painting a room
will you come in here and look at a room
look at it look at it look at it and
then just put a [__] roll around it
roll the wall and then later on I have
to get turpentine and clean off the
window sills and clean off the [__]
electrical cabinets because at night you
see how that grain that white look yeah
you see how good it looks how many times
have you gone to somebody's house and
there's paint on that white [__] cap
oh yeah on the electrical thing
so what do you do you look at the room
and you go okay let me tape it off first
and that saves me time later with
turpentine God forbid you knock over the
turpentine on the carpet now you [__]
go and the turpentine drips off the rag
because you put now it goes on the new
paint
who needs that [__] that's the [__]
old way of doing it just go in there you
have to look at things and look at them
and look at them again and go okay this
is how this is the plan for this look at
what you're working with what you you
know if you're working what your work
dates are what you have available to you
I mean there's a lot of [__]
alternatives
and you know you're moving you have a
first last security you're already
tapped out
but there's different ways to do it to
say you're on an angle you know I don't
know anything about cross-country moving
I've never done that I heard that's a
[__] nightmare I heard that's a
[__] nightmare that people come then
they they want you to give them 5 000
bucks for the furniture they hold it
Ransom I've heard horror shows about
that [__] I know about moving from point
A to point B from point A to point B
long distances it's just clothing I've
just always taking clothing that's it a
toothbrush some socks some shampoo and
you're ready to go some Q-tips
and who's gonna stop you all that other
[__] I don't know about but in short
distances
that's when you have to move your
[__] Furniture have you ever driven
like a U-Haul I think I would destroy
like the city would come to a halt if I
had a U-Haul I've driven a U-Haul but
short distance
not cross-country you know maybe I think
the most
when we moved from Seattle we took
uh a [__] camper
with a trailer with a car on the [__]
trailer
you had three vehicles yeah
like [__] the Sheikh of Arabi you
know what that's like
you know what that's I don't like none
of that [__] that [__] scares me to
[__] pieces that must have been so it
was you and Carol and a dog and a dog
and a camper trailing a trailer with a
car off of that
oh my God you have no [__] idea and
then we pull over in San Francisco
I'm standing on the street she goes to
make she Parks the car
we parked the car she goes to turn the
U-turn with just the trailer and long
you sudden you see the back wheels fall
off and you see the trailer fall on the
back and you see the back wheels just
stuck there with the hitch on it and
[__] so we gotta go ahead and get a tow
truck to tow it into a [__] up
neighborhood and park it overnight we
got to sleep in it people were having an
open mic outside a [__] door
this was the craziest week of my life
sleeping on the street in a [__]
trailer in San Francisco
what a [__] dog and people outside
your trailer singing with guitars and
[__] and shooting heroin and you're like
what the [__] is this [__] oh my God
they were talking about shooting
heroines to tie him up
you know did he have any [__] uh
cotton balls I mean it was crazy and I'm
laying there in that bed going what the
[__] have I done to deserve this [__] so
I know I hate that [__] that's the stuff
I can't tolerate like that was
that's what stopped me from moving
across country with my wife the cats
if I move across country and my wife not
have to move the wife to [__] cats
the kid you gotta stop every two hours
with the [__] cats you have no idea
my friend yeah that sounds like a
disaster yeah you have no [__] idea
when it's like you break down with cats
those [__] fry in the back seat
so you gotta have all your [__] [__]
intact you know
it's uh it's tough It's [__] tough
but like I said to you I'm I'm handling
this the right way I'm looking at I'm
going to Denver I come back and that's
when I start making my moves we're
keeping in touch with the [__]
property manager every day back and
forth letting us know what the schedule
is so once we can start it's three
little boxes every day
next week I throw every [__] out in
advance
next Monday Night by Tuesday morning I
take three or four bags that I Goodwill
up the [__] corn
all right yeah you just gotta get rid of
everything everything
are you excited for Mercy like it must
be
like I didn't grow up in an apartment I
grew up I was very lucky and I grew up
in a house
and the town where I grew up in
literally had I think maybe one
apartment complex
and I never
now when I see kids
I feel not bad but I'm like it must be
different growing up in an apartment
from a house like Mercy's gonna love
that
it's been rough the last three years
because we didn't really know we were
gonna have to travel we moved into this
place
and then we didn't know when to move out
rent own
you know I like an area
because of its convenience
you know I'm very convenient here I like
this area you know I've always liked
this area I lived in this area when I
first moved to life in three or four
months
with Carol and Vineland and more park
right yeah yeah so I like this area I've
always I know the CVS people and all the
weed stores I know the sandwich places I
know everybody up here so
I didn't think about moving to West
Hills or moving to Vegas I couldn't even
imagine Starting Over Again
so my wife said [__] it we're not gonna
find the house let's just rent one for a
year and kill some time
I was like give it a go I didn't think
we're gonna find one this quick I really
didn't
but it was in the cards and I told my
wife this is how it was going to happen
it wasn't going to happen it was going
to be a quick process just like this
happened come look at it Saturday
fill out the application and you'll know
by Monday that's exactly what happened
that's exactly what happened I'm very
happy you know I I grew up in New York
City in an apartment for a few years
but then we moved to a house in New
Jersey and there was a big difference
there was a big difference as a child
your confidence and whatnot I mean most
children don't [__] think about that
[__] well I don't even mean like the
fact that they're in an apartment I just
mean like you have a little yeah you can
be a little loud I have a friend that
has three kids that live in a one
bedroom apartment
geez he's fighting for his life and
she's fighting for her [__] life
but who could come over
they sleep in the living room
they just have beds everywhere in the
living room yeah nice people I visit
them like twice a year I know I might
bring the kids gifts I talk to them and
[__] all the time on the phone
she used to cut my hand my wife's hand
but they got three kids in a one-bedroom
apartment
so I know how unfortunate I am
I know how fortunate I am you know
it was a blessing in the skies when they
asked us to leave down there
day one day just knocked on the door and
said
the landlord found that you had cats you
have to go really I didn't know that
yeah that's the story Terry lived I
lived in there with Terry for eight
[__] years oh the first place in
Hollywood the first place in Hollywood
and one day the day after we got married
and knocked on the door and said you got
to move out
and we were like are you [__] serious
and they're like yeah you have cats
it's not in the lease Terry's been here
nine years with the [__] cats what
are you talking about
but what they were trying to do is get
though it was rent controlled apartments
right they were trying to get everybody
out redo the apartments and then charge
fifteen hundred dollars absolutely and
at first I was mad
but then it's everything else that's
been in my life they did me a [__]
favor
they did me a [__] favor
you know and I didn't even know it I was
so stressed when I moved up here I mean
the rent was going up 800 I thought it
was the end of the [__] world I never
thought I would make the rent up here
I never thought I would make the rent up
here I always thought we I barely made
rent down there how am I gonna make
[__] the rent up here
and it worked itself out Lee because
everything does you know I was thinking
about the process today
the process that
Everybody's scared of
you know there's a process in life
and we try to rush it at times but you
can't rush it it's a [__] process
and I know it from a comedian standpoint
because when I first got here myself
Josh Wolf Brody
uh you know we were very eager you're
very eager you're very eager you're very
eager
and then you start losing it
and then the situation happens that puts
you back into perspective
and then you know how to handle this
place
there's three stages to this town this
city up here
and that's what usually happens you're
very eager you're very eager you're very
eager
you start doing things you start making
little moves and then you book something
but you see a little bit behind the
curtain and it wasn't what you thought
it was going to be and the people turned
and everything changed and you bum for a
while but when you recover from that
you're a different person this time
it's tough when I see like uh Tony
Hinchcliffe is on fire right now and
he's frustrated he's eager
but he doesn't know that it's a process
and I can't explain it to him
it's very rough because if somebody
would have came to me
in 2003 and told me it was a process I
would have totally go [__] themselves
ain't no process here I'm cracking jokes
people are laughing what's the [__]
problem it doesn't work that way
it works in layers but we're always
getting the [__] process tomorrow you
walk into the union hall
and you go I want to be a [__] Union
plumber
and they say okay it takes four years of
being an apprentice
two years residential two years
commercial and then you join the
master's program I don't know the
Dynamics I'm just making up numbers here
like I've always said to me look at that
number and we look at it as so distant
but then once you do it you know you
know what I'm saying oh I I completely
understand but this is something that
I've been struggling with lately
so you said there's a process right what
I'm most worried about now is making the
wrong move
you know what I'm saying I'm worried
about like I have a couple different
options
and like like let's say someone gets two
job offers whenever that happened to me
I'd always be like [__] which one do I
take like in my mind if I take the wrong
one my life is gonna end I know probably
that's not gonna happen
but that's a big fear of mine is which
decision to make I think the biggest
mistake we make is going to people who
don't know your situation
you break your situation down to them
with your job what the benefits are what
the cons are
you know there's all that [__] right and
then
but at the end and I've said this for
years
I thought about this maybe when we still
live down there how
you always know the best decisions for
you
it's just
scared coming up with the decision
you know you're in a room you lost your
job
your wife's not talking to you she moved
back in with her mother
this is all because of drugs and you're
gambling
the last thing in your mind at that
point is going to a rehabit ending this
party
you know it's the most distant thing for
me [__] mind you're trying to figure
out how to fix it but while you're
trying to sit there and fix everything
you know this is going to be the first
answer this is going to calm everybody
down by you going to a rehab even if you
don't want to go
the people around you'll feel like these
you may have a good chance of getting
your wife back
I never thought of going through a rehab
that's why I never went to a [__]
rehab
like I never thought no [__] rehab I
couldn't imagine ending this [__]
party this charade
so like you just mean you didn't
consider it you probably had the idea
I had ideas about it we all do when
we're in that position we all know that
this is we need help
this is uncontrollable I told myself I
wasn't going to get high till Friday
it's [__] Tuesday I'm bleeding from
my nose there's a dead chick in my bed
I'm not going to work again you know
just little things and you say to
yourself what ends this
and you're like a [__] rehab
but
you know
you know that's the end so you're like
nah there's got to be something else I
can do oh absolutely but here's the the
frustrating part for me so like that's a
negative thing happening what happens
when things are going great and you have
to make a decision I'm worried that when
things are going good you know why
things are going great why because you
made the right decision so just believe
in yourself and go with your [__]
stuff
things are going great because you made
the right decisions
because you made certain decisions at
certain times
you know
I'm not here
I'm not going to Denver this week to
headline because I'm a funny comedian
I'm not even going to headline I'm not
even going to Denver
because of all the work I put into this
comically I mean like writing and
getting on stage at night and waiting in
line that's all grain Danny
how you get forward is those little
sacrifices when you stick to them
sacrifices of the [__] thing I never
realize until
I started thinking about this Jody
situation
what she was mad about years ago when a
group of people were all so angry at me
at that
I don't do enough social activities
and they're mad at you for that a lot of
people get mad at me because I don't do
a lot of things socially because
they don't get it that when you're doing
some something socially that you know
they always want to do things on nights
where it's comedy nights like Monday
nights Monday nights was the hottest
night in L.A 10 years ago you know to
have the the honor to get on stage at
the Laugh Factory or The Improv or the
start on a Monday night was [__]
greatly you know
they always had parties on Monday nights
or Thursday nights or Friday nights or
Saturday nights those are the nights
you're doing comedy
you know like my birthday is June
whatever you're in Ohio that weekend
they would look at you like why don't
you cancel it move the date this is
going to be a great party you're like
are you [__] kidding me it's the
little things I stuck to
it wasn't the time I put in or because
I'm funnier than Lisa yet it was the
little things I sucked like these are
the things I'm not doing
you know and these are the things I'm
doing granted it took me a long time to
stop doing [__] bloke but once I
stopped I stopped
and I used those other principles that
I've used in other things where you
sacrifice things
you go this is not what I'm doing this
is what I'm going to do even if I want
to do this really bad this is what needs
to be done
right absolutely and it's always planned
out for me I've been thinking a lot
about that lately how that
always worked out for me and people
never understood that part of me
well like when I tell you I'm going to
do something from two to five that's
what I'm doing
I don't give a [__] what you got going
up I already got something going on I'm
happy that you got something going on
I'm gonna do my thing you do your thing
and I'll call you at 10 after five
but people don't seem to understand that
a shame came to the show the other day
the machine Tuesday night it came last
night yeah and he came we were talking
the other day and I got you working
and he goes I'm working usually I
wouldn't answer the phone and I started
talking to them like people like him
Mitch Hedberg all those guys had
schedules where they wouldn't respond to
people
they would just lock themselves in the
room and focus on writing
you know that's very hard to do with the
[__] internet that's why I like to go
to a coffee shop when I write because I
hate the internet around
when I go right I shut the phone off and
I put in a bag
and I don't give a [__] who calls
I'll look at it every [__] 30 minutes
or something like that in my mind but I
won't look at Twitter or Facebook it's
just for calls you know right I took the
Facebook off the phone you know I taking
all that [__] off the phone anyway you
see the article saying about Irish yeah
I read it yeah you know it makes a lot
of sense I I think it totally makes
sense it makes sense I didn't understand
for people who didn't read it it was
about already giving up his cell phone
and they interviewed this like
smartphone yeah his smartphone right uh
and they they interviewed this like
Professor who was like I don't think he
I don't think it's right I don't think
other people do have an addiction to
this to the smartphone I absolutely I
get a little bit nervous if I feel like
I lost my phone or don't have it with me
I like I would get a lot more done if I
didn't have one absolutely a hundred
percent
I've really been thinking about it
yeah this thing is broken you know it's
still stuck on two [__] messages
I use the calculator once in a while I
use the notes once in a while I like the
voice recording now you taught me how to
use it even though I erased the show by
mistake I don't know what I'm [__]
doing
I don't like Twitter around it I took
the [__] Facebook off it I got the
emergency email on it just in case I
have no audition or something like that
but besides that doesn't allow me to
really distract me distract me I don't
play games I don't do Pokemon I don't
read [__] comic books
you know I have music on here but it
doesn't sound as good in the iPod and I
don't want to have nothing to have power
when I'm on the phone when I'm on the
[__] plane you know what I'm saying
absolutely it'll be on the four hour
flight you get off your power is [__]
dead on these things they got to stand
there like a mortadell and charge your
[__] phone as soon as I get another
plane I shut the [__] phone off and I
put the uh the iPod on yeah you know and
I do that so I always have my phone in
full charge what if the plane goes down
and you're on a [__] Island in baruba
and nobody can call because they've been
playing [__] Pokemon here my shit's
gonna be fold up Jack
no it's important it's important and
it's
like it's I find myself going back
through Facebook that I've already seen
like it's it's
crazy what a Time Suck It is Well
boredom boredom is a [__] thing and
you run home you open it up you see
there's somebody message you on Facebook
you see there's somebody message you on
Twitter you see if somebody got a
Hotmail I shut the thing off and leave
I do that 10 times a [__] day
just to see if somebody had needed
something with something that's what I
do but besides that I'm not on there
when I go on the weekends on the road
that computer I have doesn't let me
really do much it's such a [__]
nightmare that surface
it's such a [__] nightmare that's
what everybody wants to email me and
everybody wants to talk on the [__]
computer and you know I find [__] on
that computer when I go on the road and
I don't see on the house computer
really yeah it's [__] crazy
that's weird and going back to not
answering the phone I have a problem now
because people know that I'm not at an
office during the day I could [__] a
thousand calls that have nothing to do
about business and I feel like if it's a
family member or something I feel like I
have to take it and I look back and it's
an hour out of my day
like between two or three phone calls
like do you not answer phone calls if I
you taught me how to do that phone shut
off
soon there's days I should put that on I
forget to turn it back on so the [__]
phone don't ring and all of a sudden 35
people [__] call me
but again I'm like you I look at it and
I go I was with my daughter I couldn't
answer the phone anyway so I'm happy I
had this thing off yeah do not disturb
you yeah do not disturb thing you know
that that's it
distal limbs I forget to turn it on at
night and it runs the next [__] day
and then I go [__] nobody's called
and I go holy [__] because I don't even
look at it when I get up in the morning
I don't even look at the phone anymore I
don't turn the TV on I don't look on the
phone no more
nobody calls me after 12 no more I don't
do drugs
I look through drugs every once in a
while Ralphie calls me early and I'll
call him back or I'll call him when I
get in the car or something but besides
that nobody calls me overnight no more I
think that's a move because I'm I'm this
way and I think a lot of people in the
in their 20s are this way in my bed if
Paula's not there my cell phone and my
laptop are next to me
like in the other person's spot
it's uh like that can't be good
well you see how much time you're
wasting you see and listen man I freak
out when I go from my phone I'm a Cuban
Jew I'm thinking 400. yeah me too I'm
thinking 400 and all my numbers I gotta
start from [__] scratch now that's
what you start thinking about 400 and
all the numbers you lost that's all I
give a [__] about I gotta start from
scratch that I got a thousand [__]
numbers on this I've developed over the
years that's what I worry about
you go to your hotel and call Hamilton
that's why before I get out of the cab I
look everywhere when I get a person's
car I look everywhere sometimes I take
my phone and put it in the door oh no
yeah like get out of the car you have no
[__] idea what I've gone through some
time so now I hold on to this thing I
could have taken this thing in a [__]
year ago I just keep them I don't even
know what it is a five a three a two or
[__] six I don't know and I don't
give a [__] it's got 16 cracks in the
[__] screen I'm gonna have to take it
eventually I don't remember if it was in
the orange of your article or something
else that I read today it was probably
the audio article but it said something
like there's more smartphones in Great
Britain than there are people
and I was thinking about that I was like
how can that be
and what it is is what I think it is is
they somehow tricked us into buying a
new phone every two years they just
they're like okay you have a two-year
plan so every two years you buy your
phone
and there's really no reason to
but like I must have four phones at my
house
just doing nothing
what you donate him to the Army
the Army needs old cell phones yeah
maybe we fix them somebody was telling
me yeah you can donate from the service
okay I had no idea yeah you could go
online and they give you an address so
you can mail it to them and some soldier
in Iraq and have a [__] phone you
ever think of that no I haven't see it's
amazing amount of money we spend on that
stuff though oh no no listen these
things break they're programmed to break
they're programmed to break every 18
[__] months there's a thing you go in
there you take the chip out is that true
have you heard about that no I haven't
heard about it there's some on the
computer I think it's like a
self-destructure yeah you take it out
and now the computer lasts long I don't
know if this is true I heard this from
somebody I wouldn't doubt it I wouldn't
doubt anything that these people are
doing
I guess I don't want to buy a [__]
phone
I don't want to put that much stock into
a phone
like I was raised to stay the [__] away
from the phone
I didn't start talking to people on the
phone so I talked to girls when you're
13. right yeah and you talk to them for
hours I don't give a [__] about that
but to sit there all [__] I can't do
it no more I have to write I have to
pick up the baby you know nine out of 10
times I'm in front of people
I can't pick up a phone
that doesn't stop a lot of people now
though yeah because they're [__] rude
but if I'm in a meeting with Shane and
one of those dudes I can't pick up a
[__] phone
unless my wife calls me twice I don't
pick up the [__] phone right this is
an emergency
that's it
but then like I like I was thinking
about it
I feel bad for people who like when I
had a job job I'd be answering emails
calls and stuff 24 hours a day seven
days like you must get work emails and
it's different because you don't have a
set schedule
but at a certain point that's that
should stop like you're supposed to have
some down time well let's say I'm out
and about and I get work emails a lot of
work emails and tailed dates I can't
give them an answer until I get back
home if I'm on the road right I don't
bring my book or be on the road I don't
know where I'm gonna be that [__] day
I have an idea roughly
I have an idea but I never want to put
myself in a bad position because I have
no oh yeah I get home and also I'm like
[__] I got that thing at [__] six
o'clock then I gotta call this guy back
and tell him no so now I have a rule
I've had a rule for a few years before I
give you a [__] date I gotta go home
and check it out
that's a good rule but I mean I mean
even like
and dinner with Mercy you must get a
call about work or an email and
a certain like a certain point but you
have to like throw it away if it's not a
Jew from Beverly Hills definitely
getting [__] picked up if I'm with
Mercy
plain and [__] simple
if I'm with Mercy I'm in the table with
my wife and it's a Jew from Beverly
Hills
the phone gets baked out
but if it's not a Jew from Beverly Hills
you're in no danger of [__] getting
picked up though
I just imagine you having a group on
your phone which is the Jews from
Beverly Hills that's it if you're not a
Jew from Beverly Hills I don't even
think about it I'm with my [__]
daughter with my family
what what the [__] you know
what the [__]
and people won't understand people don't
understand that like if you don't
respond to a text right away or well you
don't respond to text at all but just
the phone calls it's too much it's too
much it's all [__] day and then you
go home and you get emails on all three
you know I got four [__] six eight
different ways to get an email
I haven't even approved people I got
emails on Lincoln then you understand me
I haven't even [__] signed up for
Lincoln then I don't even know I got on
there and I got a [__] emails on
Lincoln then okay you have a huge very
popular account yeah like I don't even I
don't want to hang out with business
associates and the same morons on my
Facebook [__] page the same [__]
morons on my Facebook page the same
[__] people on LinkedIn whatever the
[__] it is
so I you know I don't know what the [__]
where to go
I got a thousand Comics calling me did
you know that lately for what just a
thousand [__] things I get numbers on
my phone I don't even know and since I
don't have glasses I can't see them
so if the name's not in there you're in
no [__] Danger
I can't see the [__] number I got
seven one fours oshaga New York this
morning at eight o'clock I started
getting calls from somebody I didn't
even know I was outside I didn't even
[__] know until I came up to I got
three calls from the same [__] number
no message you're not getting a call
back you're in no danger you're called
to your fingers turn [__] pink but
people know they're not supposed to
leave a message with you no there's
nothing no more it says not to leave it
says not to leave nothing it's very
ambiguous there's nothing there that's
even me
nothing
I took all that [__] off done
no voicemail no voicemail if you called
me from 10 years ago on that number you
don't know who's got it now I get people
I wake up sometimes and this [__]
people Joey remember me from [__]
click and remember nobody I remember
nobody
I don't remember nobody 915 that's El
Paso that's cocaine I don't remember
nobody okay I got no memories
I don't know who the [__] is calling me
I don't know who the hell it is
hello
all right I'll be right out my love
go get the Savage Lee of debt
we got my girl Susanna coming in
she's a friend of mine that Felicia
introduced me to Felicia did a
documentary that's getting uh some heat
and it's about you want to go again
[Music]
I'm [__] believable and it's about uh
I'll let her tell you you know it's uh
they're like
I don't know what the [__] to even call
him I don't know if their sex workers I
don't know what the [__] to call them
but I did uh one of the scenes for
Felicia and I found her to be really
interesting
and I just thought about it for a long
time like uh how many [__] peep shows
I had gone to over the years you know I
didn't even want to say it like how I
met her was it Felicia documentary of
her dancing in a peep show
so she was kind of naked so obviously
I'm [__] purple the whole time she's
asking me [__] creepy questions and
[__]
but after I left and I went home
I wanted to know why in my mind got all
creeped up
when I went and did that I mean she's
just a woman she's just a beautiful
[__] woman you know she's a young
girl whatever the [__] she is I don't
even know how old she is
but why did I get creeped out so
I thought about it I said instead of me
hitting her up
I'll be going down there and taking her
clothes off or something why don't I get
her on the [__] podcast
and let's talk about what the [__] she
does how she got into it why she does it
blah blah blah blah blah blah that's it
you know what's dog we keep it [__]
simple it's buying him for Jerry's Kids
on the [__] wins and then the church
so yeah it just seemed an interesting
topic for me you know as a kid in New
York City what's happening my love
let Lee go in first and then you sit in
the middle here
My Little Princess of Beauty what's
happening
oh Jesus I'm [__] sorry about that I
like the skirt
it's you you know what I'm saying the
skirt is you
I like to attach the night that you
everything's [__] new
what's going on Lisa I had everything
good to just introduce yourself I did
yes
the edible kicked in as soon as I stood
up first they're supposed to kick in
with your [__] stand though what
would you like for me to call you on
this
uh either way Susanna
what's going on beautiful
um not much I'm uh in the middle of a 15
hour shift so
you know man people killing themselves
to live that's a lot of [__] work but
it's gonna do it you travel or you go on
the road you do stand up you [__]
sing You Dance you do burlesque oh no
singing You're a woman of a thousand
[__] things but I was telling them
that I met you when I did the
documentary for Felicia with you and it
was really weird because I've been
thinking about you ever since that
because that night
like I didn't know what to think when
you took your clothes off and stuff but
I kind of froze up you know when I went
home I was like wow that freeze up like
that
and uh I just want to get you on the
show and talk about what you do I really
found you interesting and beautiful so
that's [__] my love what's happening
um so this shift tonight where are you
working at today uh today I'm working at
my Main Place actually my only place
right now it's called Aeros station Eros
station and it's on Oxnard in Sepulveda
it's a private Showplace lingerie
modeling Private Dancer that type of
thing not like the other place I went to
no there's no glass between me and the
customer this is just me alone with a
stranger in a small room for 20 30
minutes at a time oh my [__] god
and you have regulars you said I do yeah
now how long have you been in this
industry
um well when I lived in Chicago in the
mid 90s I did phone sex towards the end
of the 90s and then I quit that I worked
for an independent service so she didn't
have really any she didn't have any
major restrictions on what people could
talk about and uh she was she was a dog
lover so she no bestiality no bestiality
and I found that out after I got a dog
call and I called her and I was like
could you please not give me any more
animal calls and she's like oh we don't
do that but here's your next customer
he's a Chester that's what she used to
call the the pedophiles
so I worked for her until I got a really
really bad pedophile like a really
terrible call on the phone yeah yeah and
then I was I was just like I can't I
can't listen this anymore
and then I didn't do anything for
let me think for several years for like
five years and then and in that time I'd
been married I moved from Chicago back
to Kansas City got married moved out to
Oregon moved back to Kansas City left my
husband and then I started doing stuff
again
but I got into it really uh I didn't go
straight into sex work you know all I
had done was phone sex I hadn't done any
in-person stuff and uh I met this guy
on Craigslist and
you know he came like I met him looking
for a guy to to like are there language
restrictions oh great so I was looking
for a guy to [__] because since I left
my husband I'd sort of like worn out all
the familiar deck that I knew so I was
looking for a new guy and I went on
Craigslist and I was uh talking to this
guy his name was James and he shows up
in my apartment and when he shows up I
see the pictures he sent were just
completely inaccurate I'm like I can't
[__] you but we both like the same drugs
and he had some so we totally hung out
you know friendly like and we did for
weeks and then uh I guess he got tired
of hearing me [__] about being broke
because you know the divorce like it
just killed you yeah and my husband had
like pilfered money before we split up
and I didn't know that until after we
split up and I checked it but you know
so uh he was like do you want to work
for me and I'm like well what do you do
I assumed it was drugs but I'm I would
I'm picky about the type of drugs I'll
sell like I don't want to sell meth or
anything I want to be part of the
solution you know not a problem right so
um he said he was a racker and I was
like I don't know what that are you a
stock boy and he was and he told me do
you know what racking is no oh it's
blatant theft from big box stores you
walk in you fill out a car and you just
walk the [__] out
so that's what we did and he he just
needed someone to distract the person in
the department that he needed because he
and the people that were in his crew
crew uh they all specialized in
different things and so James didn't
steal like cool [__] you know it was not
like TVs James stole scrapbooking
supplies from Hobby Lobby
and then resold it on eBay
right it's a [__] oh no he had a lot
of money and he had a great house
absolutely and uh so I helped him out
with that for a while and
one day we made a run from Kansas City
to St Louis and back and hit like all
the hobby lobbies all the Michaels all
the Joanne fabrics and crafts you know
and we get back and he dropped me off
and he had to go do a pill deal because
he of course he did also sell drugs
and then a couple hours later he called
me
and he was bragging about the pill deal
he's like oh I just did this big oxy
deal
and I have all this money is like uh
would you [__] me for 2500 bucks and I'm
like absolutely yes absolutely I would
and he was like kind of take he was like
oh uh what like First of all how could
you think I would say No 2 500 is that's
good money you know for very little
effort I was gonna [__] him for free you
know if he was accurate to his pictures
which he wasn't but so he was like well
I don't I don't have it all in cash
um well would you [__] me for 500 and I
was like yeah yeah I would my rent was
like 455 at the time of course I'm gonna
[__] you for 500 but then I was like you
know then I had to ask about the details
I was like well no anal and he's like
that's fine you make the rules and I was
like okay I'm not sucking anything and
he's like that's okay you make the rules
I'm like really is that okay okay I go
whoa whoa how many times do I have to do
it and he was like um you you tell me
and so I was like okay I'll do it one
time and he's like no no no 500 I want
more so we end up doing it two times but
and then he ended up [__] me out of
money over the the stealing stuff not I
mean he paid me for the [__] he
didn't pay me fully for the stealing and
what he paid me for the [__] the 500
he paid me for the [__] was the exact
amount of money he he [__] me out of
on the ceiling yeah and then he blew
town and went back to Florida uh you
know I don't know where else he would be
from but
so I realized though like it really made
me
think about that think about sex for
money and sex work and you know what was
standing in the way of me doing that
because I'd [__] like
a ton of dudes for free
you know and even bought like many guys
enough drinks to like get him drunk
enough you know and that's a terrible
thing to do to someone but that's that's
fine
um
and so I you know I thought about that
and I thought about like the the morals
and the ethics and I was never taught
that sex was something like special you
know I was never taught that it was like
something that you have to you really
have to love the person and this is what
two people who are in love do and you
know there's doves flying around and
flowers are blooming I was never I was
never taught that
and so
after [__] so many guys that didn't
give a [__] about me for free I I just
sort it just sort of dawned on me like
what am I doing you know I can I can get
laid and paid you know I can have the
the dream
so I started doing stuff on Craigslist
when I was in Kansas City I was still
living there and I started doing sex
work on Craigslist and I would look for
any AD that mentioned roses because
that's dollars and I would answer like
at first when I first realized I was one
of those people that could come you know
compartmentalize and and you know
separate like business [__] from
pleasure sex you know I I just was
answering every ad every ad I mean ads I
had no business answering [__] I had no
idea how to do I figured like I was like
well it sucks like I'll figure it out
um
and I didn't always figure it out one
time I broke a paddle on a guy's ass and
he asked me to leave his house and then
deducted the price of the paddle from
what he gave me
uh but then I stopped I don't remember
why I stopped
I think maybe no no so wait guys we'll
put out like what they want and what
they're willing to pay for it on
Craigslist yeah
well they won't say dollars though
they'll say roses so you look under
casual encounters and uh you know you'll
see like oh you come watch me jerk off
in a parking lot I have 75 roses for you
uh one time I I took a guy's virginity
while I thought I took a guy's virginity
afterwards you know my friend I thought
I took a guy's virginity and I did it
really cheap because he was like I'm 23
and I'm just out of college and I can't
afford to pay you much and I was trying
to be a really good person with it I was
trying to be sort of like you know I was
trying to I was trying to help people
with my [__] so I was like well you
know what that's fine I'll do it and
he's like I can take you out to dinner
on my Dad's credit card and it was so
cute and uh so after I did this I called
my friend Justin
and I was bragging about what a good
person I was I was just like I'm such a
good person this boy I took his
virginity he was so sweet I was nice to
him and Justin's like you're stupid and
I'm like no I'm a good person and he's
like how do you know he's a virgin I was
like well because he said so and then it
just all sort of hit me and then I I
stopped trying to you know be Mother
Teresa about it and just
stop trying to force the goodness you've
met some characters oh yeah you've seen
the [__] dark side I I've definitely
seen the dark side you know you dealt
with people that are addicted to sex and
throw it away when I was and I was
addicted to Coke I was addicted to drugs
so when you're telling me I'm
substituting these
it's all right it's all the same thing
you know that's the same thing with day
jobs it's all the [__] same if it's
not what I want to do you know comedy if
I'm not paying my bills through comedy
through storytelling through being on
stage then I don't give a [__] what I'm
doing you know I don't care I'm given a
hand job big deal it's it's like less
degrading to me than bringing some [__]
like extra lemons for her water you know
it's it's it's all the same thing
same addiction same job it's all the
same I don't want to move the Snowmass I
was 19 years old I lived in Aspen
Colorado
and I used to work security at a hotel
and every [__] time somebody checked
in they could be a couple
and he was looking really weird
like like and then he would come back to
the hole and he'd go hey
you know anybody and I didn't know
anything I really did not know what the
[__] they were talking about
and then after a while people says hey
this escorts.com and these guys are
married they got an extra [__] room I
was like what the [__] so you leave your
wife in room 212 and go to 318 and [__]
somebody else and then just walk out but
then I I equaled it to drugs like I
would I would bust into somebody's door
and take their [__] drugs and broad
daylight without even thinking about it
yeah but the whole sexual thing has
always been I'm not good at it
no I'm clunky it just never worked out
for me ever since I was a kid a lot of
people are yeah I'm [__] bad so it's
like something that I've never lost my
mind over
you know what I'm saying I knew my mom
raised me and I knew that when she said
something when I was a kid that I
couldn't think about what she was saying
she goes you can't [__] everybody
and I always over I said you know what
this girls you meet you ask them what
they say no most guys don't talk to them
anymore these guys are allies so you
become their friends you know and you
have it's so weird how I always looked
at it it was never a losing situation
for me if I asked but when I lived
in Nashville I remember walking around
thinking to myself
I'm 19 years old
what am I doing if I was a woman right
now
no college education let's say I was a
woman and I was banging what the [__]
would I be doing this working on a
t-shirt store
giggling you can get these guys for a
thousand a night they're flying in it's
in their budget they got the cash
three four nights a week four weeks you
know three weeks a month you got 12
Grand yeah
that's 140 Grand the [__] year or
something like that after five unclaimed
all unclaimed at the five years you
could buy a house go to Beverly Hills
redo your [__] and nobody knows a
[__] thing yeah nobody knows nothing
God you relocate to Massachusetts and
you live like Henry Hill the rest of
your life and you got a house you got a
little bit of Peace of Mind as a woman
no one knows your past no one knows your
past you know I always thought about
them like how the girls not doing this
but then as you grow you know you meet
different women you're like I get it I
don't get it I get it it's never been a
big line with me like I really don't
give a [__] and to me it's like you want
to get naked and get that you know I've
always been one of those dudes but when
I was growing up in Jersey we would go
to the city to peep shows yeah all right
and that always seemed
the [__] lowest and death for me like
what I saw was crazed like I used to go
to wounds on 42nd Street and then have
the rotating table and then be some
check with a cesarean scar [__] doped
up
some junkie just [__] her and you see
the Hasidic Jews in the windows at eight
in the morning like all [__] whacking
off and [__] and you'd say this is a
complete different [__] world yeah
like this is crazy and as soon as you
open the door and you step out a guy
comes in with a bucket
with water hot water and just mobs and
goes out and you step right to [__]
at least I had it was surreal
surreal how many guys how big that
business is and then they have the ones
at the window opens and you can suck
their tits and [__] like that and my
friend Pat Paris prison in the eighth
grade got his neck stuck he didn't hear
the ringer
he didn't hear the [__] ringer he got
his head stuck in there in the eighth
grade
oh that's hilarious have you ever done
any porn or just just like the the
dancing
um I
not really I did this I did this one
thing it was a Craigslist thing back in
Kansas City they were looking for women
to read stories read dirty stories
topless and it was like 250 bucks and
that was more than I'd gotten off
Craigslist for a little while and so I
uh I was like no big deal I'll do that
and
um
and I had some of the chest tattoos so I
bought makeup to try and cover them up
so I'd be anonymous
and I didn't know anything about makeup
or hair at the time and I took um my gay
best friend with me as my security and
he brought this guy that he had just
started dating it was like their second
date and it was this hotel room it was
like a
a middle-aged couple you know could have
been anyone they weren't like flashy
they weren't porny they were just they
were just like middle-aged Midwestern
couple and they just uh set it up and
filmed me reading a story about
um my name was my name was Janessa
from Denver and it was a story about how
I was a [__] girl
and uh
they sent me a link to it after it was
done
and I watched it once and it was
absolutely horrible
just terrible horrible but I figured no
one's probably gonna look at that and if
they do they get what they you know
yeah no no there's no I have no judgment
about it but it's just that that's the
one thing that I feel is like won't go
away as much maybe like and if you were
I think the emotional scars won't go
away you know if you have like
yeah you're good well yeah I just meant
like like if you were gonna strip in
like Wyoming sure and try to hide out
later in life that's possible with with
videos it's kind of on the internet I
don't know I mean I think that there's
just so much porn out there there's so
many videos that I don't I don't
I mean I know that that's a concern
for a lot of people but I've never
really
cared about that you know I'll let feet
guys if I get foot customers I'll let
them take a picture of my feet after
they're done with them uh
I mean I know feet aren't really a defy
of tattoos on my toes so they're kind of
a little more personalized but I just
never really cared about it you know I
just never figured that anything in in
like such a huge sea of material like
one person like who's gonna stumble on
your video I know it's happened but I
just talked to a girl about a month and
a half ago she used to hang out at the
haha Cafe
you know what man that whole time I knew
I had no no idea what she did until she
hit me up on Twitter one day I was in
Long Island
and she goes I live here now can you
leave me tickets and then afterwards I
didn't see her so I didn't think she
really showed up that she hit me a few
days later she thanked me she said her
Rick got drunk and they had to leave
so something happened she called me she
uh sent me her number for something and
we just Twitter back and forth and I
finally was on the road one night well
let me call him now and I called him the
daytime and that's what she told me her
whole story because she didn't know what
I was doing I was a camera girl
you put the money in the camera I guess
yeah and she goes but before that
I did porn
and she goes but the cam stuff was she
was all cracked up and stuff
because when I met her she was really
skinny so I couldn't tell what was going
on I knew something was not legit it
wasn't a healthy deal with me yeah it
was Hello Goodbye that was a funny joke
is that your dog [__] like that that was
very light so
she was telling me that she went back to
New York gained the weight went to a
rehab
got a job in the restaurant as a
waitress and after six weeks one of the
guys in the restaurant said something to
him oh
and she knows it's been a hell of a
sense for me at the restaurant like well
you should just quit and get a job she
was not that easy yeah
she went pays a car payment and a rent
and this restaurant pays well it's a
good clientele so
but I think with the Internet it's just
a matter of [__] time you know
that's [__] crazy people out there
and that's one thing that Lee doesn't
know but you know and I know I mean just
now when you said foot guys they just
come in and just want to whack off on
your feet you know you just want to do
crazy [__] yeah you sit there for my
world I think it's crazy from their
world they think it's crazy I wake up at
seven and smoke dope you follow me so
yeah
there's something like who the [__] gets
up at seven and smokes pot in the
morning but I'll go somewhere and jerk
off on some poor ladies feet or
something like that what do you charge a
guy to whack off on your feet
um well I mean technically
I don't do that right of course because
I I work legally they give you roses
yeah
um it would probably be it would you
know generally if it's 200 roses or more
I'm negotiable for almost almost
anything almost anything feet guys I
have a soft spot for because the
stripper shoes hurt and I do like a foot
rub so I will uh
you know I'll give you a foot wrap oh
yeah
oh yeah tremendous if you guys will give
you a foot rub they'll suck on your toes
they don't care how dirty they are the
dirtier the better usually and so you
know it's no big deal you want to jerk
off on my feet you want me to give you a
foot job like I don't mind that you're
nice enough to rub my feet even though
that's what you're into so
you know really you're just getting more
than you paid for but that's okay I had
a friend of mine Roger one time I said
you still got bloodshots from those
chicks you go nah not anymore I changed
my ACT they jerked me off with their
feet
I thought it was a joke obviously that's
true
I I first uh discovered that when I was
married
I would um have my husband [__] my feet
not I'd we didn't like he wasn't a foot
guy I wasn't a foot girl but I just I
wanted to feel like I was still being
affectionate towards him but I'd already
started hating him so I figured that
that was like the way to do it while
still like keeping some distance between
us
but yeah it was nice like it feels like
a nice uh like having a dick in the in
the arch you know it feels like a it's a
foot rub it's it's very nice you talk to
the Nike about that yeah like a [__]
sneaker with a dick in the orange these
people be jumping up and down
now
I mean you're the real [__] deal I
didn't know on this other side I just
thought you danced in the glass
protected nobody messed with your world
are you scared at times I mean I look at
you and I can tell that you're tough and
uh you've been in some situations
um
I've had
in the four years that I've worked at
the at the private Showplace I've had a
at aerostation I've had
three customers the entire time that I
was uncomfortable with and one of them I
kept the heel of my shoe right here in
the in his neck to keep him on the couch
because he kept trying to get up and I
kept saying get the [__] down sit the
[__] down and he just kept trying to get
up so I was like I just put my foot
there and I just let the timer run out
um and then there were two guys that
were just creepy they just had just a I
just you know really really bad feeling
and not like they're gonna jump on me
and rape me but more like they they
would kill me like they would kill me in
weird just that sort of really weird
energy but
um
I don't have a lot of fear of it uh
I in 2014 this is kind of
this is going to sound kind of ignorant
but
I don't really care uh
in 2014 a guy broke into my apartment
and assaulted me uh I didn't know him he
wasn't a customer it was nothing like
that it was just [__] maybe not
random it was random that it was me it
was not random that it was that
apartment that apartment had problems
before that doesn't matter anyway uh I
didn't fight back I just yelled at him
until he left I was in shock he woke me
up with it it was not I didn't have time
to really think about my reaction and
um so I didn't get to to fight back I
didn't get to like
you know I didn't get to fight and
oh I didn't I stayed away from work for
like a week and when I went back I
didn't know if I could do it I went back
and I was like I don't know how I'm
gonna feel about these situations and
being in the room if I'm going to be
like too nervous if it's gonna like
traumatize me re-traumatize or whatever
um
but it I actually felt stronger and I
felt less nervous about saying no and
setting boundaries and if the customer
got upset big [__] deal you get upset
fine no refunds you're upset big deal oh
you want to do something about it good
give me the chance you know give me the
chance to fight back and that's the part
that I think is ignorant because
you know I feel like now like now
I will I
I think I could I could fight any man
and I know in reality that's
you know I'm 5'2 out of the shoes it's
not it probably wouldn't work out very
well but
it keeps me feeling
you know maybe it's a false sense of
security but it's some sort of sense of
security and that's enough
usually then five foot two
well the shoes though I mean the shoes
are very very like they're dangerous
they're very dangerous
you know the heels of those things like
I said I put the heel in the guy's
throat because I knew if he I knew if he
moved you know if he tried to come at me
with a heel in his throat terrible
things would happen to him
so I don't know maybe I feel like I wear
weapons on my feet and that gives me
there's got to be some security
um um there's
the cashier who sits in the store up
front
um and
you know you're never too far away from
the other girl working so should you
scream or should something
bad happen she would probably hear
before the cashier but something I mean
like it wouldn't I'm not worried about
it I don't I feel very safe there
most of our clients have been there for
years and you know I mean we do get new
guys but
usually they find out about the place
from regular customers so usually the
guys that come in even new ones sort of
know the drill and they're they're
better behaved than
um many guys that I've just dated on the
outside like for free
you still date yeah no steady
um
not not no no currently no you tell them
what you do yeah they look just look at
you know
well I mean it hasn't been easy no it's
not easy and there's some some guys
think that
because that's my job then automatically
we're not going to be monogamous because
automatically if I'm giving some dude a
hand job for work they can go out and
[__] some girl they meet at a bar and
clearly it's the same thing
I don't feel that way
you know and when I had a steady
boyfriend I did
I did back off of what I did I was a bit
a a bit more chased with it you know
but
I don't know that you work a lot of
hours yeah you put in some [__] hours
you're busy girl yep
this place today you work at 11-1 10 A.M
to 1am
so I had a girl come in to cover
um the couple hours I'd be gone and then
I go back and stay there till 1am and
it's busy the whole day no no no no it's
dead I did one show today I I had one
customer we call them shows because
that's what they technically are
probably days a week over there
[Music]
um
it depends usually I do
four or five shifts
um this week I have let's see I worked
yesterday double today so one two three
I work Friday day and Sunday day so I'll
do five shifts this week and uh it's
it's we were closed for like three
months because of Licensing issues so we
just opened up so not all of our regular
customers know that we're open again and
yeah I mean it's always kind of dead but
it's been
it's been pretty dead the past couple
weeks I'm still good I've got all sorts
of water
now you do comedy how much comedy do you
go out a lot during the week do you get
out
um you know
I work the road pretty uh steadily until
I moved out to LA five years ago and
um you know I was featuring and you
can't really always afford to fly back
to the Midwest or fly anywhere for
future money it's a [__] nightmare so
I I just didn't really I didn't really
realize that
I didn't realize that people didn't come
to LA to work the road that they came
here to stay here and and write shitty
TV shows or good TV shows you know to
write and to do movies I I just I
thought that moving out here would help
me
on the road I thought it would help me
you know I read The Art of War and I
thought that this was attacking the
enemy from a different location
and uh
yeah
so I I thought that I was coming out
here to to like really build up my
career and I came out here and it really
[__] killed it so
it's a this is a different animal yeah
it's a different animal you have to be
prepared for it a lot of ways
um you have to be at the right place at
the right time and you don't know what
the [__] that is yeah you let me know
what the [__] that is you know that's
why I got into sex work out here because
it was the only job I could find that
would be flexible enough to allow me to
travel and when I did when I first moved
out here I was traveling the first
couple years I was still on the road a
bit but
um you know that's why I got into it out
here it was the only thing I could find
that would let me still do comedy
um so
that's
it's worked out well I run a couple
shows in town I mean and I do get up
fairly regularly definitely
usually at least a couple times a week
so you bang it out you back out the
[__] comedy yeah you bring out the
work you travel yeah because you were
just gone for 10 days yep I did The
Fringe Festival in Kansas City it was my
10th year doing it now what's The Fringe
Festival uh it's just well it's like the
one in Edinburgh these are all like all
the domestic ones are just kind of
offshoots of that one so it's sort of a
Performing Arts Festival the Kansas City
one I don't really know about a lot of
the others Kansas City has a visual or
its component too and a film component
as well but
um it's primarily performance art
um a lot of
a lot of shows and a lot of performers
that
wouldn't get into other festivals it's
more accessible for them and there's a
lot more experimental uh performances so
I've done
in 10 years let's see I started doing it
when I was a performing when I was doing
a lot of burlesque and then when I moved
out here in 2011 I started doing I
started I would go back for it and I
would do solo shows and this one that I
just did is my third was my third solo
show
and uh and I got my first uh standing up
first two standing ovations in 20 years
of doing comedy first two standing
ovations good for you man yeah I didn't
know what was happening the first one
because I say I just go good night and I
get off stage and I go backstage and
they just kept clapping and I was back
there and I'm like well they'll stop and
then they didn't I was like what the
[__] are they doing why aren't they
stopping stop clapping and then my tech
guy came back and he's like you know
you're supposed to go back out there and
I'm like why would I go back out there
the show's over maybe that's what
they're standing up and they're clapping
and I was like what what
it was something yeah that was a
that was a real like
changer
yeah is there an end game is
yeah
whatever yeah yeah when I when I don't
have to when I don't need to have that
job to pay my bills absolutely
absolutely and now does the um
comedy still ain't that dream
s and who wants to [__] freak out and
you're like wait a second I have a dream
I have a dream so
is that still your dream to do comedy
you still feel it yeah oh yeah yeah
comedy storytelling absolutely like
those are the solar shows I combine
those two and I really like I really
like that format you know I like not
performing with so many limitations with
comedy like if you're just in a
mainstream Comedy Club they have
expectations you're going to get up
there within 30 seconds you're gonna
have a laugh which I never have a
problem with FYI uh but you know they
you want to prime a setup punchline
premise setup punchline they don't want
a lot of deviation and uh with
storytelling shows they don't really
want stand up but if I do my own show if
it's a solo show I can do whatever I
want to do
jump up and down tell the story
absolutely it's done all over again so
it's pretty Innovative I like that idea
yeah I work better when I don't have a
lot of like when I don't have
limitations I work better I work better
without like a lot of things imposed
rules imposed on me I was raised to not
really respect authority and uh
and so I think that's I don't know I
think that's probably why I had problems
with a few club Owners
do you ever talk about your uh your sex
work on stage because I was thinking
like it's amazing that more comics don't
do that because like Joey you had a life
like a crazy life before a stand-up now
Julian you yeah a life that not a lot of
people
can relate like they can't they can't
even imagine so it'll be pretty cool or
if like to talk about it
I talk about this stripping and if I'm
doing the storytelling then I feel like
it's easier to talk about the sex work
to get more into it but I think with
just stand up
it would take so much time to explain
what I do that you know any jokes that
come from it it's too much setup it's
too much setup required to well for a
comedy club once you say [__]
stripper yeah you lose the guys that's
it they're looking at you from a
different perspective now yeah and now
the women are like what the [__] yeah
well it's kind of weird I can soften
that because my jokes are really the
jokes about being a stripper how about
how bad I was when I was at a strip club
I mean I was terrible I was just
horrible I'd done burlesque and I didn't
think there was I thought that was
stripping and it's so not and I was just
I just was too I was at his topless
joint right up on linkershim
um star Garden
and uh
this girl that hired me was someone I
knew from Burlesque and so
I just didn't realize there was like
much of a difference so I was up on
stage wearing like fringed panties and I
was trying to do like glove Peels and
these guys were just sitting there like
what are you doing just show us your
tits and don't smile
you know and uh
yeah so I think that because I'm coming
at it from not a perspective of like I
was a great stripper I am a powerful
stripper I think because but isn't that
the the truth with most comedy like the
underdog always always is appreciated
you know nobody wants to hear you talk
about how great you are everyone wants
to hear about like
what you've overcome I mean in a funny
way of course everyone wants to hear
about how the bad times ah but we can
laugh at them you know nobody wants to
hear about how great your day went
unless it went great for a really weird
reason you know
nobody wants to hear about the day you
you checked off everything on your to-do
list you know well I went to the post
office today everything went fine I went
to the grocery store everything was fine
picked up the kids they were a treat
nobody that's not funny you know if your
to-do list includes like
I've [__] I ended up in Mexico trying
to buy pills and everything went fine
and everything went great that's
different but nobody wants to hear about
benign [__] I don't think
they do spots at The Improv and stuff I
know that right one of my shows is at
The Improv and you get what's the show
at the Improv it's called be funny it's
a stand-up spelling bee
I'm a really good speller
Mr they can spell really well and then
where's the other show the other one is
called Dirty Birdie story hour and it's
a storytelling show themed around
deviance not just sexual but any kind of
deviance and that's at three clubs in
Hollywood second one
anytime you would phrase my sage and you
hit it from all [__] angles don't you
yeah that's tremendous man and I'm
starting another show actually
um on my birthday August 22nd and it's
uh It's a Brand New Concept I don't
think anyone has ever done it it's not
stand up it's not storytelling
it's something else what is it
conversations it's called we need to
talk and it's a celebration of the Lost
Art of conversation because I'm tired of
not talking to people I'm tired of just
looking at my phone or texting people I
went I went on like a pre-date with a
guy that I was really really into
and we texted and I'm really great at
texting I'm really great at it I was
witty I was Charming awesome and then I
went to hang out with him and I mean
I'll granted I was pretty high
um but he was too and we were sitting on
opposite couches and it just felt like a
job interview and I couldn't just I
couldn't have like a natural
conversation with this person and I just
I hate that I want to be able to have
conversations again and I think that
everyone should have conversations again
you would get out of the phone you know
just face out of the phone and talk to a
person so that's uh that's what I'm
doing it's a show comprised of 10 five
minute conversations with me
um seven booked three audience members
it's crazy try it you never listen man
at least you're working from
you know what you want to do a lot of
comics come out here and
you made some great points tonight with
the conventional comedy like when you're
going to Comedy Club they don't want to
[__] around you know I'm saying you
could you could [__] around the middle
but they want you to grab them they want
you to sell drinks they want you to do a
thousand things so it's the business
side of it
yesterday I was sitting there it's funny
how I learned to become a comic
The Comedy Store but I learned the
comedy business at The Improv
it's so weird what I grab from both
those clubs you know yeah and the Improv
they're great because they're open to
ideas you go up to the apartment because
I want to do this show okay we'll give
it a shot for three weeks and we get
people
talk about other things you know but
like I'm done like people come to me all
the time I have no idea and I want you
to do it what is it it's a stand-up show
for TV
I don't think people want to watch that
anymore you have the show on [__]
whatever you have Comedy Central and you
have HBO and you have Showtime
you know what kind of show are you gonna
do I was always looking for a show like
what you're saying you know maybe half
storytelling 10 minutes of comedy with a
panel I don't [__] know yeah but it's
2017 it's time to mix it up a little bit
you know yeah I don't have the balls
like I've always spoken the lead of
traveling with the podcast
and I just don't have the balls I don't
have the time I don't have the time to
travel with the podcast because you're
busy traveling for comedy and doing
comedy stuff and family stuff so and I'm
burnt down I'm no [__] man it takes a
lot of you to fly this last week I flew
and I didn't feel too [__] good
tomorrow well I mean please feel free to
pass any gigs that you are too tired to
do no no no
stripper is listen I know my situation
so I book liked I know what I can do and
I know what I can't though yeah you know
I know I know already so ask me and I'll
tell you and I know what I can do and I
know what I can't do you know I have a
family
so I got to be there between four and
seven four and seven thirty so I just
have all these little restrictions on me
now not to mention when I go to The
Comedy Store I got home at 12 [__] 45
yeah that means I fall asleep at two
that means I'm behind the [__] eight
ball
so that's the other thing that I'm
thinking about lately like just doing
comedy on the road
I just staying in during the week and
doing the [__] podcast you know it's
so weirdly it man before you came we're
talking about the process and part of
the process is obstacles that get thrown
at you and you have to [__] go around
them to continue your life to make your
life run smooth you know and who the
[__] knew I was gonna have a [__]
baby at 50 you know who the [__] knew
the podcast was gonna make people come
to comedy shows yeah who the [__] knew I
didn't know but you talk you do
something you stick to it
feel your belief and next thing you know
the Wiggles are in [__] motion you
know me when we started this podcast in
that [__] office
before the baby was born did you think
we'd have an office down here five years
later
and the process has been tremendous what
was part what was the whole [__]
process we just stuck with it we didn't
do nothing that nobody else didn't
[__] do
and I think I just answered my own inner
turmoil I was just about to say like I
didn't think about it I didn't really I
was just having fun doing the podcast I
really never thought about
five years down the road I and that's
weird for me because that's usually what
I obsess about
yeah so yeah oh yeah I'm I I didn't
think about like things like like
business things or where things were
going when I was first doing comedy and
I really burned a lot of bridges that I
was never able to rebuild so did I yeah
so did I I didn't think I was gonna get
this far I didn't think I was gonna
stick with it
so I didn't really give a [__] I didn't
really give a [__] you know I thought
about it from a comedians at first you
know we're all our noses open and we
want to take every gig but then one day
you talk to a friend of yours and he's
like don't do that [__] game yeah
that guy's a thief or whatever and then
you start saying no you start making
little [__] moves you know I I [__]
up I remember I wouldn't send the tape
who's your feature this week Susanna get
around the [__] hotel phone right now
we worked two weeks ago what the [__]
tape you're not gonna look at the
[__] tape
no so that's why I never set the tape I
refused I refuse to and you know what's
funny I got three jobs from blank tapes
because they don't look at the tapes
it's just a control type yeah and I've
told young Comics before a second now
it's completely different because now
you're on YouTube yeah now they just go
on YouTube and they [__] find you and
you're dead you know so right there as
they're talking to you right there as
they're talking to you uh-huh and what
do you do I'm a feature okay
uh emailing me your veils in three weeks
and I'll let you know what's going on
whatever but
there were just things I thought were
just power moves I didn't [__] like I
didn't appreciate it yeah you know you
and I are the same animal a lot of ways
I'm sitting here looking at you going
with the same animal in a lot of ways
um
the only problem with me is I'm half
approved
like I'm a half a [__] proof that
probably makes it even better just the
fact that you could like make you blush
oh no she she knows it that I'm like my
[__] uh you know I'm like a half a
[__] prude so I could have gone the
other way I just wouldn't know what
service I could have offered you know I
couldn't offer no [__] Services no
women I'm clunky and [__] are there guys
that do that [__] yeah they work for
women yeah [__] yeah the American Gigolo
is sure rich and gear 81.
stop it going over the freaks houses
right on Beverly Hills getting three
grand the poplin So shirts and [__] Lisa
yeah we'll make you one of those
[__] down there
going down and slinging dick down there
some little you gotta give them a back
rub firstly you know yeah my mind is I
just never imagined the girl would want
that well like a lot of you know
best case scenario high-powered rich
women don't want the [__] of dating
so they're like okay I need a someone to
go with me to this event let me find
someone real pretty yeah and then he's
gonna [__] me afterwards because I'm
gonna pay him enough money
you know and
I don't well I don't want to say
anything go go what the [__] I think a
lot of those a lot of the um
Gigolos are gay are gay men
um
why just so they don't have any like
emotional feeling for it or like I don't
know if that's the reason I don't know
if it's like
I don't know I mean I know there's
straight men that do it too but I don't
know if if they get like overly excited
like like a little dog just jumping up
like oh I get to [__] you for money oh
yay you know I don't know if it's that
or if it's if it's just I'm not really
sure because I've never really uh it's
not that's not my bag yeah I would like
to pretend that that wouldn't be me but
if anyone offered me that that would be
cute little Jewel come over your house
and Holocaust your [__]
[Laughter]
tremendous with a picture of Hitler on
it forget about it you'll be getting 10
[__] calls an hour
Suzanne only I'll be making 10 off you
making [__] a day that's it right
there that's great Hey listen I just
found my house listen run Jeremy has
never won a [__] Mr American Contest
no and he made millions of dollars
[__] [__] women yeah but I don't
have one Jeremy's dick who knows maybe
you got something a different Pizzazz
maybe you got the ass of a star maybe
women will love your legs they'll say
you know that legs like Elvis they love
the hair on your leg and [__] like that
you never know Lee you got to give it a
shot there's a fetish category for for
whatever you are whoever you are
whatever you have you show up dressed up
who play what's Sean Penn what's that
character you played in uh
show up dressed like Kleinfeld the
[__] attorney Jew and [__] uh
what's that movie Carlito's Way remember
I didn't see that one see this is why I
can't talk to you no more I can't talk
to you want to Sean Penn's greatest
performances you never [__] saw it
because yeah you just say you could come
over dressed as a as a seed you come
over dressed as a judge an eternity you
could be a thousand different [__]
characters little room glasses I got
ideas though ten percent goes to Uncle
Joey I can pimp you out down in Beverly
Hills Culver City and [__] Brentwood
areas
I'm down do it
that's crazy now the other job you had
behind the glass I can't touch you that
correct
um there's lap dances there as well at
the other place yeah where I went to
there peep shows and lap dances and so
technically no you can't touch but
you know
lap dances or lap dances and
if you tip you know they're better lap
dances I thought you just did the the
boot thing that was in over there that
was always very interesting to me I
thought about you and I said you know
what man
I gotta talk to her why I have this fear
of all this sex [__] like it just makes
me go [__] like I feel [__] up when I
walk into those places well I mean
they're kind of [__] up places like
that that place is dirty dirty place
yeah but I've never gone to one of those
places that ain't dirty that's what
gives me exactly that's the Poetry of it
that's what I loved about it went to a
place one time that
I don't know if people have PTSD
or people had trauma but I gotta tell
you something that night [__] me up
for a couple years
because I saw some weird [__] that night
in the early 80s New York City was a
[__] oh yeah you know just the king
of that [__]
when I was in the [__] seventh grade
I had these two brothers
Juan and Alberto Ali one was legit the
other one got hit in the head with a
rock in fact one day I had him in the
head with a [__] rock I threw it up
in the air he looked up and hit him
right here and he had a lump with a
[__] cyst in the middle but we used
to hit each other with light bulbs from
durotest like the long ones and little
ones because they would always have uh
dysfunctional [__] light bulbs and
they just throw them in the dumps anyway
to make a long story short these kids
were in the [__] eighth grade you
said
should be 13. Alberto was stupid
so he was maybe 15 but he was still in
the eighth grade they went to different
classes they came from Cuba said I don't
know how to speak English
so until you learn they just kept you in
the seventh grade and then when you got
to the seventh grade and B16 or driving
they put in a program called the pilot
program
and you went into high school as a
sophomore
so it was kind of weird but anyway to
make a long story short being in the
seventh and 8th grade with Alberto and
one and they would come to school on
Monday
breakdown wow they would take a bus to
the Bronx
go to a place and then take you to a
place and you pick the girl and my heart
would stop it's never telling me the
stories
how the chick would wash your dick and
then you would she would [__] you asking
what you wanted and it was like cheap I
would sit and go what the [__] are you
talking about
and I never thought about it my
perverted mind and years later
I went out with these guys one night the
kid had a candy truck and they took me
out to this place called the 1040 Club
and it was 9.99 plus tax 10 [__] 40.
it's 1982 10 40. oh and I don't remember
if you paid when you were back there
I don't remember if you paid extra when
you were back there but they threw you
into a lounge
all these guys were cloned they were
looking at the score on like those guys
come in like a one in the morning now
they can't score so they want to get
some [__] yeah
I don't know if we could ask him like
Pablo you won it was one like well you
come here a lot and he's like yeah I
come here all the time it's great the
girls are great they were from another
country they even [__] speak the
language they were scared to be there
and they were [__] Susanna in
cubicles yeah like there was no rooms
Jack yeah it was office cubicles and you
would just go into the office Cube and
there was just a wall and she would take
a bucket out from the under the bed and
pour water on it and they have a sponge
and she'd wash your dick let me explain
something to you I had never experienced
anxiety those women started washing my
dick
with this [__] sponge
and she asked me what I wanted to do I
couldn't even talk Suzanne I couldn't
even talk so I just laid down she got on
top of me and she started bouncing and I
couldn't stop
like thinking of all the [__] that was
gonna happen to me like I just couldn't
stop like and the men kept going back
right when it was one of those beds and
he just opened up and it was the thin
mattress in the middle and it had been
used for years and she's on top of here
I don't know what to do I couldn't come
I couldn't react I just laid it in the
middle after two minutes she just
stopped and she goes you know
for an extra ten dollars you're gonna
eat my [__]
and I remember like I just threw her off
me and I just put my pants on and ran
out of that and that was it for me that
was it
like that was it for me
was it the impersonal nature of it
or the fact that it was reduced to such
a business endeavor
both both
it was just [__] horrific I couldn't
believe guys were in there like it just
[__] killed me and then you know I
was a half a [__] I had regular
girlfriends and [__] I didn't really
know nothing about nothing
and then when I got into comedy in 91 I
got divorced and I started doing comedy
and I started meeting people on the road
and I met this one girl that just took
me for the ride of my life I still
talked to her I still talk to her she's
crazy she got two kids though she
married an Indian dude that was 80 and
he died and left the 3 million oh this
chick oh yeah but she still strips once
a week in the town over
so I think she was like in Sarasota and
she strips in Tampa and she's got living
boyfriend he doesn't know what she's
just a [__] animal you know she's
just a real deal
you can't even contain that [__] with
the animalistic [__] in their heart but
I gotta tell you something at that time
I had been to prison I had done a
thousand things
she was telling me [__] but I was like
my draw would draw
why she was telling me stories of her
going to college and some guy was paying
her rent in a [__] her once a week and
that's it sugar daddy yeah he just come
over [__] her and leave he didn't care
what she did nothing
and she had to take a trip somewhere
she would go with him and he'd give an
extra 3 000 [__] dollars it was just
I didn't know about this world
I swear to God I had no idea about this
world man it was [__] crazy to me
so uh
I ended up dating her for like four
years that was just it was just an
experience going to pick her up at the
strip club like you know and then
driving home but I just felt [__] uh
and it was weird because a friend of
mine always says that one day I got
really funny when her and I broke up
everything in my life changed
because it seemed like me being with her
was holding me back like something was
[__] with me and it was it really was
[__] with me you know she was on a
strip club she was hustling I knew what
she was [__] doing I'm not [__]
[__] you know what I'm saying yeah
you can't [__] the [__]
so it just it's weird today I still talk
to her because if it wasn't for her I
wouldn't have been in L.A so I don't
forget anybody yeah that's the truth of
the matter she was the one that's on
this little [__] lame let's give it a
shot you know so I can't uh put it down
for any reason it was just her walls
ain't got to be here soon
let me give some shout outs and I'll get
you the [__] out of here where's my
glasses I'm going old
don't forget Denver this weekend and
next Friday the Ice House
Dylan Bailey beloy John Cutler and Amy
Margaret Oliver Crystal Oaks Davin Cole
Jr Brett Rogers Joey Brooklyn making it
happen Randy Hill
Joshua manculo Mancuso and Greg and Lynn
up there in Seattle I owe you a call
Greg I didn't forget about you
[__]
that's it I gotta go to Denver this
weekend man I gotta tell you something
that has I think that's what [__] got
me sick this week just the thought of
going to Denver the answer my necks have
been sticking up you know I have a 26
year old daughter no and she wasn't I'm
sure she wasn't living but my accent is
involved we haven't talked we just don't
talk every time I go over to Denver
I just feel shitty for a few minutes you
know I let the Denver in that area for a
long time
and it's a real beautiful city and I
always felt like I disrespected I got
arrested
a [__] rocket ship that's like the
[__] Twilight Zone you know I always
felt like I disrespected like I got
arrested there I went to prison [__]
Boulder
oh wow yeah for kidnapping bothering
[__] yeah yeah it was a fun day so uh
the crazy thing is that now I've always
been ashamed of going back to Colorado
like I always been the mountains are
beautiful and I disrespected the
mountains you know I thought this way
for years
so for years I was banned from this club
in Denver
that's what made me leave then we're
getting banned from The Comedy Works oh
yeah you follow me so yeah once I got
banned from the comedy race I was like
what the [__] am I gonna do about the
work mcelvey's what's that we're gonna
do that die did that die
so I had my daughter who was five at the
time and I just talked to the mom and
saying I moved to L.A and then we kept
the relationship cool for a few years
but then it just went silent when she
was like 10 or 11 they went to England
for two years it's just
so the daughter doesn't talk to you no
we don't talk at all I've tried you know
so
every time I go back there just uh it's
just a weird feeling that you get like
your little neck head a couple of [__]
it's fine I go back there and do my
comedy I get some green chili and go for
a walk in the high amplitude
and I get to see uh this is the first
Club I ever got on stage at June 18th
1991 this is the first [__] club
that I've been on stage on so it's
always great to when I got banned from
there it was pretty it's really weird
Leland before you show up we're talking
about the process of your life
and the things that happen what happens
to your mind like you think you're dead
and you're really not have a debt to
your dad you're not dead today put you
in the [__] casket
you're not dead to your [__] dead man
because I thought I was banned from the
[__] Comedy Works
like people would say that'd be her hey
I want to bring Joey Diaz the featured
she'd go another million years you
banned for life
and I bumped into her in Denver at the
Oddball tour
and she goes are you mad at me like why
would I be mad at you because of you
I did something with my life you forced
me to do something you push the hand
I had to come out of here and leave and
move to Seattle and start from scratch
so
now I'm working for her again after that
she called my agency because we had to
talk I want a book in my [__] club so
everything you know this is where I
started so this is like kind of uh
emotional when I go back there I got
that I got no ties I got no
war and stuff like that you know
everything's cool I just uh go back
there relax and do kind of eating each
other I'm looking [__] forward to it
man I really am I'm looking forward to
this week and it's one of those weeks
this is one of the best clubs in the
country have you ever stepped one day no
I talked to her on the phone once in the
90s yeah the Comedy Works downtown
that's uh yeah it's been there a long
time it's been there for sure for 25
years because that's when I stepped on
the [__] stage and it was probably
there 15 years before that
so they have another one now that's in a
more Suburbia I would mean that's the
Improv right no yeah how many words
there's two locations in The Improv The
Improv is a nice club I worked that one
first before I worked the county worse I
worked yeah nice place I was going into
Denver for a burlesque Fest and uh I saw
Al canal in the airport who was managing
The Improv at the time and I hadn't seen
now uh for years
Al's you know quote unquote managed me
for like a few minutes real few minutes
um and uh yeah he said it was a nice
place and
um such a great guy
I think he's back in Missouri now listen
man I'm happy you came in here
open up as much as you did it was very
interesting I'm an open book no I know
now what's the name of the documentary
there with Felicia
um Felicia's documentary is called perv
and the web series that I created was
called papin comics
and
um yeah that should be very interesting
yeah before now what's a pedophile a
pedophile is somebody who molest kids
yes well someone who is attracted to
Children someone who sexually attracted
to Children you know whether they act on
it or not you know the urges are
a little before you said pedophile and I
tried to put two into it so together if
they're in there giving you a foot rub
they're not pedophiles no
but maybe
the pedophiles and training working
themselves backwards and [__] and it's a
podophile right Podiatry is foot
doctoring so it wouldn't
hold it listen man
I love a woman's foot in this shoe I
really love a woman's foot in the shoe
when I see a woman's ugly foot and she's
got it in the room's [__] shoe it
pisses me understand me yeah when they
got a long foot and they put them in the
lung in those launch pad shoes yeah and
they have a twister on their ankle don't
do that makes your foot look [__]
longer don't do that [__] Ty you know
what I'm saying the different shoes I
always I love women's shoes but I gotta
tell you something I would never suck a
woman's toe never not even if it's super
super clean [__] no no [__] no no no no
no no no I wish I could do a replay
because when she was saying that I
switched to your camera because you your
eyes were just shut
you're just so sad oh yeah [__] no I
don't know that I would suck a guy's
toes oh no and I don't I generally
unless somebody is really really good I
do not go near manasse or if I'm in love
I'm in love I'll put a finger in the ass
but men's asses no no I had too many bad
experiences
it's [__] disgusting because you're a
gentleman you're a gentleman and a
scholar no you have to bathe if you're
gonna go into those [__] places and
[__] you can't go in there all [__]
stick you gotta go home put some cologne
on whatever the [__] you got I don't
wear cologne but personally whatever the
[__] it it's just uh
I like you I like you I think that uh
you're interesting as [__] I think
you're a out the box thank you
completely different than the rest of
the broads you talked in L.A they're all
uh cut from the same cookie they're all
chasing the same nickel yeah
it's nice to know you're not chasing the
same nickel you know uh
we have a time right now in this country
where we're about to get the Lewis Fair
you know I mean I can't blame him I mean
uh Trump's [__] [__] so they give
you the I mean he just talked his way
out of this [__] thing whatever
absolutely and uh we have this lowest
fat you know and you see all these women
with women power and stuff
I think real women Powers when I see a
woman like you thank you I see a woman
that uh
is living life under her [__] terms
scares the [__] out of me you know the
whole dominant now I gotta add you to my
life I gotta think about you three in
the womb that you bring her home tonight
some guy trying to bite her [__] toe
up
but you uh
I'll always make it home don't worry
you go to Starbucks and you see these
women who think they're uh they're doing
something they wouldn't watch that
[__] stupid movie
you know what's the movie when she went
over to Saigon what's that movie with
the chick from seven oh oh the the uh
three words yeah you pray love no the
other one that's the other one this is
the one I thought it was that one no
that's the one with the uh
right the one that came out with the
chick from Saturday Night Live that you
get breaks up with the guy and she goes
over the [__] Iran and she meets
Turkish people and [__] like that you
know
you see those women and they're sitting
there at a [__] Starbucks talking
about their adventures and [__]
Bangladesh and [__]
and three other women like sitting there
drooling from themselves and then again
I see a woman like you who's banging it
out the real deal banging it out doing
comedy you know listening to [__]
perverts and [__] which at the end of
the day you'll listen to when you do
comedy as a woman
every [__] night you get abused every
[__] night somebody says night's tits
you got nice ass you know uh you open up
the [__] stripper gate on these
[__] morons yeah yeah it's a [__]
nightmare as a woman trust me I was on
the other side of that so I know how
creepy we get that time but
you know uh on the road I've been
treated worse by the men in in the
comedy industry than I've ever been
treated by the guys that I've stripped
for or done whatever for you know I've
I had a I had a club owner ask me to
blow his landlord between shows on a
Friday
once it was right after the only the
only time I ever got fired from a club
and so when he asked me to come in the
office I was like oh [__] I'm gonna get
fired again oh no because I thought it
was just a snowball thing and I went and
he goes my landlord is at the show and I
was like I'm really gonna get fired and
he goes and he liked you and then I was
like I don't know what's happening now
and he goes would you blow him and he
must have seen my face like just fall or
do something because he goes oh no no I
would pay you
so uh yeah I did you negotiate it you
said no I was just like no no that's
good that you keep them I was like 23 at
the time
well this was before any of that this
was yeah because what did you get one
blow job on the road
uh lee what do you got going on [__]
liquor
uh what do I got going on I have a
couple more podcasts this week and uh
Paula Comes Back Sunday
You're locking her up Sunday night it's
over and [__] yeah she's in room with
Henry actually Henry's there oh my God
Henry who everybody from Jujitsu and me
yeah who's Henry
Henry Houlihan yes
okay nice nice all right
and that's it that's uh
that's all you got don't worry about I
gotta go to Denver I'll be back Sunday
next week we're on we're on Monday and
Wednesday next week I want to thank
Susanna Lee right yes thank you for
coming on the show tonight I also want
to thank our sponsors number one as
usual on it I love you [__]
I've been doing the mixed greens lately
and it's tremendous I've been taking the
shroom Tech again it's tremendous I've
been back on the hemp Force protein
again you know I got a box every like
three months I bother them and I get
reacquainted with the products and [__]
like that and I gotta tell you it's
better than [__] than ever the shroom
Tech I'm I ate I got my blue mouth
something must have happened so you have
that there number two speaking about
blue belts geese rash guards bags ghee
bags they have one of the best you know
how I always talk about preparation
absolutely nobody like that to Sarah put
together a bag for jiu jitsu that's more
prepared
I got knee pads in there I got knee pads
for the knee pads I got an extra belt I
got an extra rash guard in there I got a
water bottle and I got a backup water
bottle canteen so the water stays at the
[__] temperature you understand me
there ain't no [__] [__] around
when I finish class now the water's warm
I got four packages I got an extra
zipper down then I can hide my little
protein powders down there they even
give you a little bag to put your Rask
on it so the wet rash guard doesn't
touch your [__] ghee this is the
technology that's usara okay and all the
products are made with hemp whether it's
their tremendous geez whether it's their
tremendous rash guards or the famous
fanny pack as we call it I got mine
ready for tomorrow vapor pen papers
Aspen for the heart you know the whole
[__] deal you understand me some
gummy bears I got everything ready to go
to Denver so that's what I'm talking
about fanny pack rash guards the ghee
the Hem gee is superb I dropped 20
pounds I'm in that [__] doing
Sidekicks into flying on bars you
understand me but do me a favor go to uh
dsgear.com and go to the page take a
look at the colors they have take a look
at the supplies they have whether it's
the bag that you're looking for or a new
video a new rash guard take a look at
the fine selection and then what are you
doing you use code Joey and you're gonna
get five percent off five percent off
delivered to your house
dsgear.com right or wrong absolutely
right okay I gotta give you a rest Godly
you look nice in a [__] brass contact
a little brass guard for you also all
jokes aside if you're looking for a
great travel bag Jiu Jitsu back to
sorrow look at that one I have it's
[__] phenomenal I'll take a picture
next time I go to Jujitsu I love you
[__] thank you for coming on my
little princess thank you for coming on
I want to thank on it I want to thank
Natsu Sarah and I want to thank all you
[__] for listening and giving
me your time have a great weekend be
safe and we'll be back Monday stay black
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
foreign
[Music]